oh this guy looks like an Irish model
this gentleman right here is a Sinead
O'Connor Rage Against the Machine wattle
this guy's coming to kill ya
there's no chuck-e-cheese wherever he's
at
moving on to rep my earth sink my ink my
name is Garrett coming at y'all from
white-trash America Lawton Oklahoma got
a little sing my ink three fellas you
know got the area called the shade 580
on the arm by my best friend on 17 got
in my dining room table mr. mom and dad
we're pretty happy with me about that
face Tagget that J for Jesus baby hey
Louie Vuitton on us Oh probably get them
removed eventually got the cult leader
himself mr. Jared Leto probably my
favorite pieces right here that's all
work looking wild got venom got got the
baby mama Harley Quinn on arm to boy
kicks ass Gang Gang Buzz Lightyear he
wanted skipped over that anarchy tattoo
on his [ __ ] dick bro but that means
if you want some of his wiener bro
you're getting some inr that's I mean if
a woman if she complained after like
hooking up with him you can't complain
they have that right yeah you know like
hey your honor
Exhibit A Anarchy tattoo you knew what
your son we're just from my weight he
kicked in my door
he doesn't need a shady 580 I think
that's one of the best things I've ever
heard man out a lot in Oklahoma jabs at
17 in your living room sting it bright
hard sting I've made some mistakes yeah
I'm gonna say I'm gonna say King it man
I like that I like I like bad tattoos
that people have gotten some of these
look pretty good man no his or those
those Joker ones the the cart the comic
book Joker on his rib piece there's
pretty [ __ ] legit yeah he's got a
couple of jokers
is a black widow tattoo which usually
means you killed somebody in prison but
that's whatever you tattoo
I'm sure he's your model sis and his
face tattoos louis vuitton it's probably
only Louboutin in Oklahoma oh whatever
this dude is definitely fist-fought
somebody at a Jimmy John's before did I
talk [ __ ] about the Oklahoma Sooners
around this guy look man I'm I guess I'm
just a little afraid to talk but I don't
need that one is a spider I don't even
get so I think it's a real spider he has
that's just a living
sound the workers on his PEC right there
uh she would have gotten some more of
them died see tattoos here's some real
[ __ ] on there man I mean what I like is
I like the shady one from the beginning
I think being willing to let somebody
else unless you did it yourself like
this I like that old shady style like
when I was growing up people would get
it with a little thing in ink and that
took forever and the needle and it was
no game plan no sense
so no straight line yeah somebody who
didn't even definitely can't even read
or spell with the right and your friends
on [ __ ] Mountain who he can handle
shaking hands but you get it done one
way or the other man that shady 580 gang
brought like a man thanks for sending a
man dude
[Music]
King
[Music]